Raymond.
Uh, sir, the And by the way, this is why
you can't do a deal with Ukraine and
including Germany. I mean, the national
security Raymond when it came in on
Thursday night, I said, "We got to
[laughter] have Raymond on." It's like,
it's like Raymond uh wrote this, sir.
Um, you've seen the strategy paper of
President Trump when he talks about
Western Europe, the eraser of their
civilization in 20 years. one of the
senior people in AFD just agreed that
this the collapse and maybe turn in she
said hey it's optimistic 20 years if we
don't come to power you've spent your
professional life writing these three
series of books over the last what 8 n
10 years that talk about when the west
has had to confront this before and the
west won but it has to be confronted
talk to me about this period of time
we're going to go back to your books but
as you drop your third book in the
series here in the Christmas season, the
president of the United States lays out
a strategy that essentially says
everything that you've been telling your
audience is absolutely 100% true in
modern times. Sir,
>> that's right, Steve. um you know
listening to Brix right now it's just
amazing because um as I think of the
past and what I write about in the
history that we we will be discussing
it's just it's hard to overlook the fact
that the fundamental problem the big
difference now is that the west is doing
everything to enable and empower its
enemies including domestically bringing
them in to terrorize them because that's
the fundamental difference when you look
at the past and the present Islam has
not changed the Muslim modus operandi
has not changed it's always been
consistent. It's always been upfront and
open and it's been about conquest. And
so when you look at the history that's
which we'll talk about, you'll see that.
But the difference is back then everyone
in Europe uh you know from the warrior
monk uh Christians to the most
secularized uh whoever politician uh in
in that context all understood the
danger all stood collectively against it
all fought against it and um and this is
at a time when Islam was actually very
powerful compared v to the to Europe. Um
and then you you know you fast forward
to our times and you know Islam is
inherently weak. Okay. But western
powers are empowering it, bringing it in
to their countries, making sure nobody
can say anything against it, imprisoning
their own native populations because
they speak up or complain because
they're being terrorized and just do
everything possible. So I think it's
just amazing and mindboggling to see how
different things are. you know the the
consistency of Islam on the one hand the
continuity and then on the other hand
you know the western sort of suicidal
response that has gone from standing up
and fighting doing what needs to be done
to actually confronting a much weaker
Islam but still being terrorized by it
because you're allowing it to terrorize
your people. So that's uh you know
that's I think we have to start there.
That's the first premise really. I want
to go through the arc of of the of the
and this is third in the series. Sword
and scimitar is the first and lays out
the whole thing of the combative nature.
Then you actually take examples
defenders of the west. You actually take
biographical
of of of of men who really stood in the
breach uh at critical times and the big
battles and what happened. And now
you're actually going and taking the
warrior monks these two uh the Templars
and the and the St. John hospitals did
that really fought in the middle of
this. Walk me just through the arc of
it. What were the three books and what
ties them together and why did you write
them in this series? Sure, Steve. The
first one, like you said, sort of
simitar came out in 2008, 20,000 2018.
And that one was really a continuation
of my academic studies back in the day
under Victor Davis Hansen, you know, in
the early late 90s. Uh my master's
thesis was actually the first battle
between Islam and the West, the battle
of Yarmmuk, which formed chapter one of
Sword and Zimitar. But I've always been
interested in, you know, we've all we we
all grow up uh in the modern era hearing
about the great, you know, uh the
advancement of Islam and Andolucia and
how backwards the west was and etc etc.
So I've always been very much interested
in studying the actual military history
and then you lo and behold you find out
that is what dominates the real history
between and the interactions between
Islam and the west or christryendom at
the time. And so sword and scimitar what
I wanted to do is really look at all the
decisive battles that have completely
changed the face of the globe especially
the old world east of the Atlantic that
maybe many people are unaware of due to
all the entrenched you know narratives
that academia foists on people which is
why everyone who reads starting with
sword and zimitar the first response is
oh I thought I was educated I thought I
had a degree in history and I didn't
know any of this okay so you come to
learn for example that in the seventh
century Islam explodes and conquers
essentially threearters of Christendom.
You know what we now today glibly refer
to as the heart of the Islamic world
from the Middle East, you know, from
Morocco all the way to Iraq, North
Africa in the Middle East and later
Turkey or Anatolia. All of that of
course was the heart of the Christian
world and it was violently enexed in one
century after the death of Muhammad and
until 732 now they're in France at the
battle of Tours. So I think I showed um
how how persistent Islam was. I have a
nice important quote from Hiller Balac
uh 19th century died in 20th century
historian very insightful who basically
says Islam is our most persistent and
formidable enemy and may explode at any
time and he wrote that I think around
when Islam was at its nadir. It was
absolute weakest visav the west at the
time. this is the colonial era and you
know he predicted it and and lo and
behold here it is again right Islam has
has exploded so that was the purpose of
the u of um the sword and scimitar and
it really went century after century you
know all and and what's interesting to
me and what I think the book shows is
the um unwavering continuity of
hostility so you see from the very first
chapter the battle of yarmmuk in 636 AD
the rationale that the Muslims gave to
the eastern Roman Empire the Byzantines
during in that battle was you're an
infidel. Our Quran says to fight you,
enslave you, etc., etc. I give you the
three options, convert, fight or die.
And you fast forward um the last real
battle I cover is the first Barbary war
or and the second right around 1800 to
1815 and you find the same exact
rationale at work. Thomas Jefferson, you
know, this great luminary, enlightenment
luminary who didn't really understand
Islam, you know, the bar the the the the
Muslims of Barbrey, North Africa had now
been attacking American sailor vessels,
enslaving American soldiers. And um so
Jefferson and Adams, John Adams, met
with the ambassador from I believe
Tripoli, Abdul Abdul something, it's in
my book. And they asked him, why are you
attacking us? Why don't we get along?
Why don't we trade, etc. And this guy in
Thomas's Jefferson's extent letter we
still have to Congress, he explains how
this man told him, you know what, it's
in our it's in our Quran. Our God, our
prophet tell us, you're the enemy. We
have to attack you. We have to plunder
you and enslave you. Okay? And and and
of course, Thomas Jefferson didn't get
that at the time. But so I just I think
that's the lesson of Sword and Scimitar,
which is how unwavering this violence
has been. It's never stopped. It's
always it's blown up in certain areas at
certain times. There were the Arab
conquest. Then you had what happened in
Spain which was a microcosm of jihad and
crusade or reconista. Then you have the
holy land which people are familiar
with. But it really goes much more than
that. You have the Ottomans and the
Seljixs. And then you have the Tatars or
the Mongols who became Islamic and
conquered Russia in the eastern Slavic
uh nations. And the whole nine yards of
Islamic uh persecution of Christians is
evident in that chapter as well. slave
raids all the way up into Ireland and
Scandinavia and uh having an actual base
off of England where they would raid and
bring slaves back to North Africa. So,
it's a very deep history that most
people are unaware of uh for political
reasons obviously. And um that's yeah,
so that was the whole purpose of Sword
and Scimitar. But before I continue with
the other books, I'll I'll leave it
there.
>> No, no, no. Let's go to let's go to
that's perfect. Let's go def then
defenders of the West. You go back and
you highlight the personages in the west
that have actually stood in the breach
and say no and and some of them are
tragic stories, some heroic stories.
Tell me about defenders of the west.
>> Sure. So defenders of the west that's
the next one the follow-up came out in
2022 and as I say in that book whereas
sword and scimitar what I had what I did
is focused on eight decisive battles
that really changed the face of uh the
old world in defenders of the west I
looked at eight decisive men. And so the
lesson really it was it's I I cover the
same terrain more or less but now it's
through the eyes and the lives of
various heroes military Christian
heroes. Okay. And you know, the first
one is uh Godfrey uh in chapter one of
the first crusade and we go all the way
down to Vlad the Impaler, which is a
shocker to most people uh that Count
Dracula is actually a Christian hero.
But if you look in again in the sources,
that's exactly how he comes off and
that's that was his interest is
defending uh you know his people against
Islamic aggression. Um, so the whole
point I think in defenders of the west
and a lot of people like it is I think
it's a little more whereas sword and
scimitar is more factual and you'll get
the grand overlay. Defenders of the west
is now you know more particular and it's
more biographical. So it's eight
chapters many chapters of these various
heroes and defenders and warriors and
how they actually approach the Islamic
menace. And I think it's very and and
this one really underscores the
difference between what you just heard
from Beatric um in Germany and whatnot
and uh what's what how how
historically Christians and Europeans
responded to this menace. Okay, they
they got it.
>> They got it and these heroes got it.
They stood in the breach. We got a
minute before we go to break. The the
third the third book in the series talks
about the military orders or the or the
monks that fought back. Tell me about uh
two swords.
>> So the two swords of Christ, that's a
new book that just came out and it's
it's similar to both books in the sense
that it's a long history like sword and
scimitar of the fight between um
Christendom and Islam and it's similar
to Defenders of the West because it's
really zeros in on the heroic aspect,
but now it's not individuals. It's
actually this collective organization of
monks, military orders, and really
they're much different in a way than the
defenders of the west characters because
they're very anonymous. Uh, you know,
they're very modest. They're the most
they're they're essentially commando
forces. They were the backbone of the
crusades. And what's interesting about
them is the way they wed militancy with
piety which is so and I think that's the
most interesting aspect of the book to
understand how Christians back then
could actually be the more pious they
were the more militant they were. So
that's the new book and and we can talk
some more about after break.